the birds-of-prey official teaser
trailer has just dropped and with it
comes a host of new costume looks styles
and speculation in this trailer we see
flashes of Black Canary
Huntress Harley Quinn and more Quinn
once again played by Margot Robbie is
reprising her role as the villainous
slash antihero and since her breakout
success in Suicide Squad she is now
headlining the movie Jared Leto is not
returning as the Joker and this film
will be more focused on her exploits
outside of the squad
jurnee smollett bell and mary elizabeth
winstead will be featuring in the film
as Black Canary and Huntress
respectively bringing the characters to
the big screen for the first time for
those who don't know what Black Canary
is pretty much tied into the arrow
universe with the character even
marrying Oliver Queen and the comic
books though from the teaser he does not
seem to feature however due to the
characters popularity on the small
screen
I would imagine a cameo or at least
Easter egg from the character Huntress
herself has a diverse backstory that
differs depending on who is writing it
and which continuity the comic is in
Huntress is sometimes depicted as the
daughter of Batman and Catwoman however
I highly doubt that this will feature in
the film instead I would imagine that as
they are seemingly rebooting Batman as a
younger character that they do not want
to stifle him with the daughter and are
using the Helena Bertinelli aversion
Bertinelli was born into a mafia family
and became a vigilante yet taking them
down as she grew in reputation before
eventually being noticed by Batman and
recruited for his bar family while she
turned down this position and she still
works as a close ally she has already
featured an arrow alongside canary so it
seems like DC are trying to capitalize
on this dynamic once more Ewan McGregor
- features in the trailer and he is
confirmed to be Black Mask who is a
prominent Batman villain the character
is commonly depicted as a brutal and
ruthless crime lord in Gotham City who
has a fixation with masks and derives
sadistic pleasure from the act of two
chair mask most notably recently
featured in the game are from origins
and he controls a vast criminal empire
throughout Gotham City Cassandra Cain is
- said to feature and this silent
protagonist is the best hand-to-hand
fighter in the DC Universe and initially
did not speak as she had been raised by
her assassin father to read nothing but
body language thus heightening her
ability to fight Victor Zsasz is - said
to feature and he will most likely be an
ally of black mask the serial killer
carves tally marks into his skin upon
every successful kill and it's clear
that Warner Brothers may end up with the
character looking something similar to
kill manga in black panther so that's
all we know so far but I'll make sure to
keep you up-to-date as more news comes
in if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out the
first screening reaction forces am which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]